Hey there Shankar here. As we reach the end of 2017, there are four words you almost never hear, whether that's from people in the news or from friends and family. You're right, I'm wrong. We don't hear those words and we don't say those words because we all have elaborate mental defenses to keep threatening ideas at bay. These psychological defenses can give us a short-term boost, even as they expose us, to long-term risks. We're taking a bit of time off this week, so we thought we'd share a conversation from March with the neuroscientist Talley Sherrod. We found this episode helped us understand why it's so hard to listen to ideas that challenge
大家好，我是香卡。随着2017年接近尾声，有四个字你几乎从听不到，不管是从新闻人物那里，还是从亲朋好友那里。你说得对，我错了。我们听不到这些话，也不说这些话，因为我们都有精密的心理防线，来把那些具有威胁性的想法挡在门外。这些心理防御机制可能会给我们带来短期的心理提升，哪怕它们同时让我们暴露在长期的风险之中。我们这周要休假一段时间，所以我们想分享一段3月份与神经科学家塔利·沙罗特的对话。我们发现这一集帮助我们理解了为什么很难听进去那些挑战我们信仰的观点。
our beliefs. It also gave us some techniques to help us see the world with fewer biases and preconceptions. As you gather with friends and family to celebrate the New Year, we hope you'll find it useful too. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedenthu. There are certain issues where we just don't see eye to eye with people on the other side of the political aisle. Often, it feels like we don't just disagree over policy, we can't even agree on the facts. I think people are mostly just setting their ways. I would say I'm right objectively, the facts prove that there is global warming. I don't know how you can dispute it.
它还给我们提供了一些技巧，帮助我们以更少的偏见和先入之见来看待世界。当你与亲朋好友聚在一起庆祝新年时，我们希望你也会觉得它很有用。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是香卡·维丹坦。在某些问题上，我们与政治光谱另一端的人就是无法达成共识。通常情况下，感觉我们不仅仅是在政策上有分歧，甚至连事实都无法达成一致。我认为人们大多只是墨守成规。我会说我是客观正确的，事实证明存在全球变暖。我不知道你怎么能对这一点产生异议。
But everybody thinks they're right. I think they're wrong. I think they're making a huge mistake because security has to be a very big issue. My guest today has spent years studying the way we process information and why we often reach biased conclusions. She says it's surprisingly difficult for us to change one another's minds
但每个人都认为自己是对的。我认为他们是错的。我认为他们犯了一个大错误，因为安全必须是一个非常重大的问题。我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间研究我们处理信息的方式，以及为什么我们常常得出有偏见的结论。她说，我们要想改变彼此的想法，难度大得惊人，
no matter how much data we present. But just a little bit of emotion, that can go a long way. Tali Shahraut is a cognitive neuroscientist at University College London. In her upcoming book, The Influential Mind, she explores how our minds work, why we ignore the facts, and how you can get people to actually listen to the truth. Tally, welcome to Hidden Brain.
无论我们提供多少数据。但只要有一点点情感，就能发挥巨大作用。塔利·沙罗特是伦敦大学学院的一位认知神经科学家。在她即将出版的新书《影响力的思维》（The Influential Mind）中，她探讨了我们的思维是如何运作的，我们为什么会忽视事实，以及你如何才能让人们真正去倾听真相。塔利，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。
Thank you, great to be here. Some months ago, you were listening to a Republican presidential debate, and Candida Donald Trump was asked a question about the safety of childhood vaccines. Here's what he said. You take this little beautiful baby and you pump. I mean, it looks just like it's meant for a horse, not for a child. And we've had so many instances, people that work from it,
谢谢你，很高兴来到这里。几个月前，你正在听一场共和党总统候选人辩论，候选人唐纳德·特朗普被问到一个关于儿童疫苗安全性的问题。他是这么说的。你把这个可爱的小宝贝抱过来，然后注射。我的意思是，它看起来就像是为马准备的，而不是为儿童准备的。我们有这么多的实例，有人因此而，
just the other day. Two years old, two and a half years old, a child, a beautiful child, went to have the vaccine and came back and a week later got a tremendous fever, got very, very sick, now is autistic. Tali, you're a mom. You have two small children. At the time, Trump said this, one of your kids was two years old, the other was seven weeks old. Describe your emotional reaction to what he said. Yes, so when I was listening to Trump at that debate,
就在前几天。两岁，两岁半，一个孩子，一个漂亮的孩子，去打了疫苗，然后回来，一周后发了高烧，病得非常非常重，现在得了自闭症。塔利，你是一位母亲。你有两个小孩子。特朗普说这番话的时候，你的一个孩子两岁，另一个七周大。请描述一下你听到他所说的话时的情感反应。是的，所以当我听到特朗普在辩论中的那番话时，
I was already quite concerned because I was a mother of a small child, so you're always concerned about the health and safety of your kids, especially when they're only a few weeks old. And so it really tapped into this fear that I had and the anxiety that I already had. And when he talked about this huge syringe, a horse-sized syringe that was going to go into the baby in my mind, I could imagine this syringe, a horse-sized syringe that was going to go into the baby. In my mind, I could imagine this syringe inserted into my small little child and all the bad things that could happen.
我已经相当担心了，因为我是一个小孩子的母亲，所以你总是担心孩子们的健康和安全，尤其是当他们只有几周大时。所以这确实触及了我内心的一份恐惧，以及我原本就有的焦虑。当他谈到这个巨大的注射器，一个马匹大小的注射器要扎进婴儿体内时，在我的脑海里，我可以想象出这个注射器，一个马匹大小的注射器要扎进婴儿体内。在我脑海里，我可以想象这个注射器插入我幼小的小孩子体内，以及所有可能发生的坏事。
And this was a very irrational reaction on my end because I know that there's not an actual link between autism and vaccines. But it's not enough to have the data. Ben Carson, Dr. Ben Carson, was on the other end. Well, let me put it this way. There have been numerous studies, and they have not demonstrated that there's any correlation between vaccinations and autism.
这在我看来是一种非常不理性的反应，因为我知道自闭症和疫苗之间并没有实际的联系。但光有数据是不够的。本·卡森，本·卡森医生，当时在另一边。好吧，让我这么说吧。已经有很多研究表明，它们并没有证明疫苗接种和自闭症之间存在任何相关性。
But that wasn't enough, because the data is not enough, and even if the data is based on very good science, it has to be communicated in a way that will really tap into people's needs, their desires. If people are afraid, we should address that. I'm curious when you sort of contrasted, you know, the weight of the evidence on the one hand, and this very powerful image of the horse syringe and your seven-week-old baby on the other hand. How did you talk yourself into trusting the data over that emotional image? What really helped is that I understood what was happening to me,
但这还不够，因为数据是不够的，即使这些数据的科学依据非常好，它的传达方式也必须能够真正触及人们的需求、他们的欲望。如果人们感到害怕，我们就应该解决这个问题。我很好奇，当你把一方面的大量证据，与另一方面那个关于马用注射器和你七周大的宝宝的极具冲击力的形象进行对比时。你是如何说服自己去相信数据而不是那个情感形象的？真正有帮助的是，我理解了自己身上发生了什么，
you know, the first instinct was like a stress and anxiety, but because this is what I study, I knew what my reaction was. I knew where it was coming from. I knew how it was gonna affect me, and I think that awareness helped me to put it aside and say, okay, I know that I'm anxious for the wrong reasons, and this is the action that I should take.
你知道，最初的直觉就像是压力和焦虑，但因为这就是我的研究领域，所以我知道我的反应是什么。我知道它来自哪里。我知道它将如何影响我，而且我认为这种意识帮助我把它放在一边，然后说，好吧，我知道我的焦虑是没有道理的，而这是我应该采取的行动。
It's a little bit when you're on a plane and there's turbulence and you get scared. But telling yourself, I know that turbulence is not actually anything that's dangerous. I know the statistics on safety and planes and so on. It helps. It helps people reduce their anxiety. The facts don't always relieve our anxieties though. helps people reduce their anxiety.
这有点像你在飞机上遇到气流而感到害怕。但你告诉自己，我知道气流其实并没有什么危险。我知道飞机安全等方面的统计数据。这有帮助。这有助于人们减轻焦虑。不过，事实并不总能缓解我们的焦虑。有助于人们减轻焦虑。
The facts don't always relieve our anxieties, though. Sometimes, they only harden our views. Sometime ago, Tally did a study where she presented information to people who believe that climate change is real and to people who are skeptics. She found, for both groups, people strengthened their pre-existing beliefs when new information confirmed what they thought, but both groups, people strengthen their pre-existing beliefs when new information confirmed what they thought, but both groups ignored information when it challenged their views.
不过，事实并不总能缓解我们的焦虑。有时，它们只会让我们的观点更加固执。不久前，塔利做过一项研究，她将信息分别呈现给相信气候变化真实存在的人以及怀疑论者。她发现，对这两组人来说，当新信息证实了他们的想法时，人们就会强化自己原有的信念，但对两组人来说，当新信息证实了他们的想法时，人们就会强化自己原有的信念，而当新信息挑战他们的观点时，两组人都会选择忽视。
I asked Ali about this. Our psychological biases are the same across individuals on average. We all have what's known in a confirmation bias. A confirmation bias is our tendency to take in any kind of data that confirms our prior convictions and to disregard data that does not conform to what we already believe. And when we see data that doesn't conform to what we believe, what we do is we try to distance ourselves from it. We say, well, that data is not credible, right? It's not good evidence for what it's saying.
我问了塔利关于这方面的问题。我们的心理偏见平均来看在不同个体之间是相同的。我们都有所谓的确认偏误。确认偏误是指我们倾向于接受任何能够证实我们先前信念的数据，而忽视那些与我们既有信念不符的数据。当我们看到与我们的信念不符的数据时，我们的做法是试图与其保持距离。我们会说，嗯，那些数据并不可信，对吧？它不是其所言事物的良好证据。
So we're trying to reframe it, to discredit it. I want to sort of push back at you just on one point, which is sometimes it seems to me that it actually might be rational to reject data that comes in. If I've seen gravity work all my life, it makes objects fall toward the ground. And you take me into a room where an object seems to be levitating. It seems to me the appropriate reaction is not okay, everything I knew about gravity was wrong, but let me try and understand this anomaly. Let me try and understand why this object is not doing what it's supposed to do. It seems to me and I'm clearly betraying my own beliefs
所以我们试图重新构架它，去抹黑它。我想就一个观点向你提出一点反驳，那就是有时在我看来，拒绝涌入的数据其实可能是理性的。如果我一生都看到重力在起作用，它让物体向地面下落。而你把我带到一个物体似乎在悬浮的房间里。在我看来，恰当的反应不应该是“好吧，我关于重力的一切认知都是错的”，而是“让我试着去理解这个反常现象”。让我试着去理解为什么这个物体没有按它应该的那样做。在我看来，而且我显然背叛了我自己的信念，
here, given the overwhelming weight of evidence that climate change is real, showing me data that one winter is colder than normal shouldn't make me change my overall view. Should it? You're absolutely right. So the way that people tend to update their beliefs is that they use the new information in light of what they already believe because that on average is the rational way to go. Exactly as you said, when we encounter some kind of information that really contradicts what we believe very, very strongly, on average that information is wrong. Right, so I give an example in my book where if someone comes in and says, I just saw pink elephants flying in the sky and I have a very strong belief, obviously I just saw pink elephants flying in the sky,
鉴于气候变化是真实存在的压倒性证据，向我展示某一个冬天的气温比正常情况冷并不能改变我对整体局势的看法。难道不是吗？你说得完全对。人们倾向于更新自己信念的方式是，他们结合自己已经相信的内容来使用新信息，因为平均而言，这是理性的行事方式。正如你所说的那样，当我们遇到某种确实与我们坚信不疑的观念严重相矛盾的信息时，平均而言，那个信息是错误的。对吧，我在书中举了一个例子，如果有人走进来，说我刚刚看到粉红色的象在天空中飞，而我有一个非常坚定的信念，很显然我刚刚看到粉红色的象在天空中飞，
and I have a very strong belief, obviously, that no pink elephants fly in the sky. I would then think that they're either delusional or they're lying, and there's good reason for me to believe that. So it's actually the correct approach to assess data in light of what you believe. There's four factors that determine whether we're going to change our beliefs. Our old belief, our confidence in that old belief, the new piece of data and our confidence in that piece of data. And the further away the piece of data is from what you already believe, the less likely
而我有一个非常坚定的信念，很显然，没有粉红色的象会在天空中飞。我就会认为他们要么产生幻觉了，要么在撒谎，我有充分的理由去相信这一点。所以，根据你所相信的来评估数据，其实才是正确的方法。有四个因素决定了我们是否会改变自己的信念。我们原有的信念、对那个原有信念的信心、新获得的数据以及我们对该数据的信心。而且，新数据与你原有的信念相差越远，它就越不可能
it is to change your belief. And on average, as you go about the world, that is not a bad approach. However, it also means that it's really hard to change false beliefs. So if someone holds a belief very strongly, but it is a false belief, it's very hard to change it with data. When we come back, we're going to talk about some of the ways we can reshape the beliefs of other people or our beliefs, and try and answer the question, if throwing good information at people doesn't drive misinformation out of circulation, how do you get people to buy the truth?
改变你的信念。而且平均而言，当你在这个世界上行事时，这不是一种糟糕的方法。然而，这也意味着要改变错误的信念真的很难。所以，如果一个人对某个信念坚信不疑，但那却是一个错误的信念，要用数据去改变它就非常难了。当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些可以重塑其他人信念或我们自己信念的方法，并试图回答这样一个问题：如果向人们抛出好的错误信息无法让虚假信息退出流通，你究竟该如何让人接受真相？
Stay with us. In often fields as though fear is used to motivate us to act. The vast majority of Americans today do not feel safe. On Sunday, Americans woke up to a nightmare that's become mind-numbingly familiar. This could be the great trojan horse of all time. Politicians use fear to get us to vote. TV programs use fear to get us to keep watching. Public health officials use fear to get us to quit smoking. I ask Tally whether fear might be an effective way to persuade people to change their minds and maybe even their behavior.
请不要走开。通常情况下，感觉恐惧被用来激励我们采取行动。今天绝大多数美国人都没有安全感。周日，美国人在一场已经变得令人麻木地熟悉的噩梦中醒来。这可能是史上最大的特洛伊木马。政客们利用恐惧来让我们投票。电视节目利用恐惧来让我们继续观看。公共卫生官员利用恐惧来让我们戒烟。我问塔利，恐惧是否可能是说服人们改变想法、甚至可能改变行为的有效方式。
Fear works in two situations. It works when people are ready, stressed out, and it also works when what you're trying to do is get someone not to do something, an inaction. For example, if you try to get someone not to vaccinate their kids, fear may work. If there's an apple that looks bad, I don't eat it. Fear is actually not such a good motivator for inducing action, while hope is a better motivator on average for motivating action. You talk about one study in your book where a hospital managed to get its workers to practice hand hygiene, to get staff members to wash their hands regularly.
恐惧在两种情况下起作用。它在人们已经处于压力之下时起作用，而且在你想做的事是让某人“不做某事”——即不采取行动时也起作用。例如，如果你试图让人们不给孩子接种疫苗，恐惧可能会起作用。如果有一个苹果看起来很糟糕，我就不吃它。事实上，恐惧并不是促使人们采取行动的好动力，而希望平均而言是激励行动更好的动力。你在书中谈到了一项研究，其中一家医院成功让其员工实践手部卫生，让员工定期洗手。
But it turned out the most effective thing was in frightening the staff about the risks of transmitting infections. It was something else. So in a hospital on the East Coast, a camera was installed to see how often medical staff actually sanitize their hand before and after entering a patient's room.
但事实证明，最有效的做法并不是让员工对传播感染的风险感到恐惧。而是别的东西。所以，在东海岸的一家医院里，安装了一个摄像头，用来查看医务人员在进入和离开患者病房前实际给双手消毒的频率。
And the medical staff knew that the camera was installed and yet only one And the medical staff knew that the camera was installed, and yet only one in ten medical staff sat as their hands before and after entering a patient room. But then an intervention was introduced, an electronic board that was put above each door, and it gave the medical staff in real time positive feedback. It showed them the percentage of medical staff that washed their hands in the current shift and the weekly at rate as well. So, anytime a medical staff will wash their hands and numbers will immediately go up and there will be a positive feedback saying, you know, good job. And that affected the likelihood of people washing
医务人员知道摄像头已经安装好了，然而只有十分之一的医务人员在进出病房前对双手进行了消毒。但随后引入了一项干预措施，在每扇门上方放置了一个电子看板，它向医务人员实时提供积极的反馈。它向他们展示了当前轮班中洗手的医务人员百分比，以及每周的洗手率。因此，每当有医务人员洗手时，数字就会立即上升，并且会出现一条积极的反馈，说，你知道，干得好。这显著影响了人们洗手
their hands significantly. It went up from 10% to 90% and it stayed there. Instead of using the normal approach, instead of saying, you know, you have to wash their hands because otherwise you'll spread the disease, basically instead of warning them of all the bad things that can happen in the future, which actually results in inaction, they gave them positive feedback. One important idea that Tally has explored is something known as the equality heuristic. It's a mental shortcut and it's really quite simple. We tend to assign equal weight to everyone's opinion.
的可能性。它从10%上升到了90%，并且一直保持在那里。他们没有使用常规的方法，没有说“你知道的，你必须洗手，否则你会传播疾病”，基本上没有警告他们未来可能发生的所有坏事（这实际上会导致不作为），而是给予了他们积极的反馈。塔利探讨过的一个重要概念被称为“平等启发法”。这是一种心理捷径，其实非常简单。我们倾向于赋予每个人的意见相等的权重。
But sometimes when there's an expert in the room, this mental shortcut can lead us a stray. Different people have different expertise and it's better to put more weight on people who are more knowledgeable or have more expertise in the domain that we're making the decision in. And there's been a study showing that this equality heuristic is something that people do around the world. So it's not something that people do only in democratic governments, but studies have been conducted in other countries such as China and Iran,
但有时，当房间里有一位专家时，这种心理捷径可能会让我们误入歧途。不同的人有不同的专业知识，最好把更多的权重放在那些更有知识、或者在我们正在做决策的领域拥有更多专业知识的人身上。已经有研究表明，这种平等启发法是世界各地的人们都会做的事情。所以这不仅仅是民主政府下的人们才会做的事，中国和伊朗等其他国家也开展过研究，
and there too, people go according to the equality heuristic. If they need to make a decision, they will get the opinions of quite a few individuals and then tell you them up, and that's how they make the decision, instead of actually using the person in the room who is more knowledgeable and has more expertise. But how can you know who the expert is? When your question is about cancer, you can turn to an oncologist. But for other questions, many people might claim to be knowledgeable. It turns out there's a clever technique to separate the experts from the pretenders. It's called the surprisingly popular vote.
在那里，人们同样遵循平等启发法。如果他们需要做决定，他们会征求相当多人的意见，然后把它们加总起来，这就是他们做决定的方式，而不是去真正利用房间里那个知识更渊博、拥有更多专业知识的人。但你怎么知道谁是专家呢？当你的问题关于癌症时，你可以求助于肿瘤科医生。但对于其他问题，许多人可能会声称自己知识渊博。事实证明，有一种巧妙的技术可以将专家和冒名顶替者区分开来。这被称为“惊人受欢迎的投票”。
Let me show you how it works with an example. I have two questions for you. The first is, what's the capital of Brazil? Okay, here's the second question. What do you think most people will say is the capital of Brazil? Maybe you thought the capital was Rio de Janeiro, but maybe you knew the right answer, Brazil By looking at the results of those two quick polls, I can tell you with no prior information that the capital of Brazil is Brazil How would I know that? Because if I think Rio de Janeiroissonario is the capital of Brazil, I will also think that most people think that.
让我用一个例子向你展示它是如何运作的。我有两个问题要问你。第一个是，巴西的首都是哪里？好了，第二个问题来了。你认为大多数人会说巴西的首都是哪里？也许你以为首都是里约热内卢，但也许你知道正确答案是巴西利亚。通过查看这两个快速民意调查的结果，我可以在没有任何先验信息的情况下告诉你，巴西的首都是巴西利亚。我怎么会知道呢？因为如果我认为里约热内卢是巴西的首首都，我也会认为大多数人这么认为。
However, if I think Brazil is a capital of Brazil, I will still think the Rio is the answer that most people will give. So what this ends up being is that Brazil will be an answer that's more popular than people expect. I have to say it took me a minute to understand how this idea works. It's complicated, but it really is very clever. Here's another example. Let's look at a math problem.
然而，如果我认为巴西利亚是巴西的首首都，我仍然会认为里约是大多数人会给出的答案。所以最终的结果是，巴西利亚将是一个比人们预期中更受欢迎的答案。我不得不说，我花了一分钟才理解这个理念是如何运作的。这很复杂，但确实非常巧妙。这里还有另一个例子。我们来看一道数学题。
In a lake, there's a patch of lily pads. Each day, the patch doubles in size. If it takes 48 days for the patch to cover the entire lake, how long would it take for the patch to cover the entire lake, how long would it take for the patch to cover half the lake? The correct answer is 47 days, because the lilies double in area every day. If they fill the lake on day 48, they will fill half the lake on day 47. But the intuitive answer is the 24th day, because 24 is half a 48.
在一个湖里，有一片睡莲。每一天，这片睡莲的大小都会翻倍。如果这片睡莲覆盖整个湖泊需要48天，那么这片睡莲覆盖整个湖泊需要多长时间，这片睡莲覆盖一半的湖泊需要多长时间？正确答案是47天，因为睡莲的面积每天都在翻倍。如果它们在第48天填满整个湖，它们在第47天就会填满半个湖。但直觉上的答案是第24天，因为24是48的一半。
If you ask people what the answer is, most people will say 24, a few people will say 47. When you ask people what they think others will say, nearly everyone will predict that others will say 24. Since more people say the answer is 47, then expect others to say the answer is 47. 47 turns out to be the surprisingly popular vote answer and the correct one. It's basically a clever way to figure out who has expert or insider information. Betting markets work on a similar idea. If there's someone in a group who has knowledge about something and you give them a financial
如果你问人们答案是什么，大多数人会说是24，少数人会说是47。当你问人们他们认为别人会说什么时，几乎每个人都会预测其他人会说24。既然更多的人说答案是47，那么比预期其他人会说答案是47的人还要多。47最终成为了“惊人受欢迎的投票”的答案，而且是正确的。这基本上是一种找出谁拥有专家或内部消息的巧妙方法。博彩市场的运作理念与此类似。如果群体中有人对某事有所了解，而你给予他们经济上的
incentive to come forward with that information, you can bring insider information to the surface. So the surprising popular vote tends to predict the correct answer in many different domains. It can be factual, it can be math, it can be even estimating the price of art. So they did a little study where they asked MIT students to estimate the price of art. Now, MIT students, for the most case, they don't really have a lot of knowledge about art.
激励让他们说出这些信息，你就可以让内部消息浮出水面。因此，“惊人受欢迎的投票”往往能在许多不同的领域预测出正确的答案。它可以是事实性的，可以是数学，甚至可以是估算艺术品的价格。所以他们做了一个小研究，让麻省理工学院的学生来估算艺术品的价格。现在，麻省理工学院的学生，在大多数情况下，他们对艺术其实并没有太多的了解。
And yet, when they asked them to estimate the price of art, and also to say what other people will think about that, and they took the surprising popular vote, the surprising popular vote, the spot on. I wrapped up my conversation with Talley by exploring one last idea about how we might convince others to listen to the truth. It had to do with a study of Princeton students who got their brain scanned while they listened to a story of a young woman named Annabelle. Producer René Clarre read an excerpt from that story.
然而，当要求他们估算艺术品的价格，并说出其他人会对此有何看法，然后他们采用了“惊人受欢迎的投票”时，“惊人受欢迎的投票”结果准确无误。我通过探讨最后一个关于我们如何才能说服别人倾听真相的理念，结束了我和塔利的对话。这与一项针对普林斯顿大学学生的研究有关，他们在听一个名叫安娜贝尔的年轻女子的故事时接受了大脑扫描。制作人雷内·克拉克朗读了该故事的一个片段。
I know everyone has some crazy prom stories, but well, just wait. I was a freshman in high school in Miami, Florida, and I'm new to the freshman scene. I'm new to the high school scene, I should say, and it's almost December, so I've been in high school for about three months, and this boy Charles asks me out. He's British, he's a junior, and he's really cute. But sort of shy, but just, well, it doesn't matter. So I say yes, I'm excited." The story goes on. It includes, as Tally writes, love, rejection, blood, alcohol, and a couple
我知道每个人都有一些疯狂的舞会故事，但是嗯，等着瞧吧。我在佛罗里达州迈阿密读高一，对于高一新生圈子来说我是个新人。我应该说，对于高中圈子来说我是个新人，而且快到十二月了，所以我已经在高中大约三个月了，然后这个叫查尔斯的男孩约我出去。他是英国人，读高二，而且真的很可爱。但有点害羞，不过，嗯，没关系。所以我答应了，我很兴奋。”故事还在继续。正如塔利所写的那样，它包含了爱情、拒绝、血、酒精和几名
of policemen, all the requirements of a bestseller. I asked Tally to tell me what happened in the minds of the Princeton students as they listen to that story. So this is a study that was conducted by Professor Hassan's group at Princeton. And what they showed is that when one person listens to another person's story, the activity in the two brains synchronize. So if you're listening to me, then it is possible that the activity of your brain looks a lot like the activity in my brain. And at the beginning, the activity in your brain listening to my brain, it will be delayed in a little bit, right? So I'm thinking about
警察，具备了一本畅销书的所有要素。我让塔利告诉我，当普林斯顿大学的学生听这个故事时，他们的脑海里发生了什么。所以这是一项由普林斯顿大学哈桑教授的研究团队所开展的研究。他们所展示的是，当一个人听另一个人的故事时，这两个大脑中的活动会同步。所以如果你在听我说话，那么你的大脑活动看起来就很可能非常像我大脑中的活动。一开始，你听我说话的大脑活动会稍微延迟一点，对吧？所以我正在思考
something, I'm saying the words, you're perceiving the words, and then the activity in your brain will follow the activity in mind. However, they found in that study that after a while, the brain of the listener started proceeding the brain of the storyteller because the brain of the listener was predicting what the storyteller will say. So, if you looked at the listener brain, you could predict what the activity in animals brain would look like. But the idea of synchronization seemed to be important for influence.
某些事情，我在说这些词，你在感知这些词，然后你大脑中的活动会跟随我大脑中的活动。然而，他们在研究中发现，过了一会儿，听众的大脑开始领先于讲故事的人的大脑，因为听众的大脑在预测讲故事的人将会说什么。所以，如果你观察听众的大脑，你就可以预测安娜贝尔大脑中的活动会是什么样子。但这种同步的概念似乎对影响力很重要。
Why? In another study that the same group did, they found that when people were listening to very strong speeches, what they found was the brains of the different people listening to those speeches started synchronizing. So if we all listen, for example, to Kennedy's famous moon speech, her brains would likely look very much alike. Those who came before us made certain that this country rolled the first waves of the industrial revolution, the first waves of the industrial revolution, the first waves of modern invention,
为什么？在同一团队做的另一项研究中，他们发现当人们在听非常有力的演讲时，他们发现听这些演讲的不同人群的大脑开始同步。所以如果我们都去听，例如，肯尼迪著名的登月演讲，我们的大脑看起来很可能会非常相似。我们前面的人确保了这个国家迎来了工业革命的第一波浪潮，工业革命的第一波浪潮，现代发明的第一波浪潮，
and the first wave of nuclear power. And this generation does not intend to founder in the backwash of the coming age of space. We mean to be a part of it. We mean to lead it. And this is not only in regions that are important for language and hearing, it's also in regions that are important for emotion, in regions that are important for what's known as free-rear-of-mind, our ability to think about what other people are thinking, in regions that are important for associations. And you try to think, well, what's common to all these influential speeches that can
以及核能的第一波浪潮。而我们这一代人不打算在即将到来的太空时代的逆流中沉没。我们打算成为其中的一部分。我们打算引领它。这不仅发生在对语言和听觉很重要的区域，它也发生在对情感很重要的区域，发生在对所谓的“心理化”（即我们思考别人在想什么的能力）很重要的区域，以及发生在对联想很重要的区域。你试着去想，嗯，所有这些能够
cause so many people's activity to synchronize, And one of the most important things is emotion. If the storyteller or the person giving the speech is able to elicit emotion in the other person, then he's actually having somewhat of a control on that person's state of mind. So think about it like this. If you're very sad and I'm telling you a joke, well, you're sad. So you're not going to perceive the joke as I perceive it when I'm happy.
导致如此多人的大脑活动同步的有影响力的演讲，它们的共同点是什么？其中最重要的事情之一就是情感。如果讲故事的人或发表演讲的人能够引发另一个人的情感，那么他实际上就在某种程度上控制了那个人的精神状态。所以你可以这样想。如果你的心情非常悲伤，而我在给你讲个笑话，嗯，你是悲伤的。所以你不会像我快乐时那样去感知这个笑话。
But if I'm able to first make you happy and then tell you the joke, well, then you'll perceive it more from my point of view. So by eliciting emotion, what you're able to do is change the perception of everything that comes after. To perceive information as the person who's giving the speech wants you to perceive it. So you can see how this coupling, this idea that the audience is mind and the speaker's minor in some ways coupled together. You can see how this could potentially be used to spread good information. You know, you have a great teacher in high school and you're captivated by the teacher and you're being pulled along by the story the teacher is telling you, maybe about history or maybe about geography.
但如果我能先让你快乐，然后再给你讲这个笑话，那么你就会更多地从我的角度去感知它。因此，通过引发情感，你能够做到的是改变对随之而来的一切事物的感知。以演讲者希望你感知的方式去感知信息。所以你可以看到这种耦合，即听众的心智和演讲者的心智在某种程度上耦合在一起的这个概念，是如何潜在地被用来传播好信息的。你知道，你在高中时有一位优秀的老师，你被这位老师迷住了，你被这位老师讲述的故事所吸引，也许是关于历史的，也许是关于地理的。
But you can also see equally how the same thing can work in the opposite direction that you could be listening to a demagogue or you could be listening to somebody who has a very sort of captivating rhetorical style and this person could also lead you astray in just the same way that the great teacher can lead you to knowledge and to positive things. Absolutely. whether we will be influenced by one person or ignore another person, are the same whether the person has good intentions or bad intentions, right? The factors that affect whether your influential can be, can you enlist it in motion in the other person? Can you tell a story? Are you taking into account the state of mind of the person that's in front of you? Are you giving them data that confirms to their preconceived notions? All those factors that make one speech more influential than the other,
但你同样也能看到，同样的事情如何能在相反的方向上起作用，你可能会听一个煽动者的话，或者你可能会听一个拥有某种非常引人入胜的修辞风格的人的话，这个人也可能把你引向歧途，就像伟大的老师能把你引向知识和积极的事物一样。绝对的。我们是会被一个人影响还是会忽视另一个人，这些因素都是一样的，无论这个人是怀有善意还是恶意，对吧？决定你是否具有影响力的因素可以包括：你能否激发另一个人的情感？你能否讲好一个故事？你是否考虑了你面前这个人的精神状态？你是否给他们提供了符合他们先入为主观念的数据？所有这些让一场演讲比另一场演讲更有影响力、
or more likely to create an impact, can be used for good and can be used for bad. Tali Sharad, I want to thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. today. Thank you so much for having me. This week's episode was produced by Maggie Penman and Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle, a special shout out to our former intern Chloe Connelly, who interviewed the Liberals and Conservatives we heard at the start of this episode. Our staff includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah and Renee Clark. This week our unsung hero is Brian Malford of National Public Media. NPM is the group that sells our sponsorship messages. Brian is a great mix of
或者更有可能产生影响的因素，既可以用于善意，也可以用于恶意。塔利·沙罗特，我要感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我。今天。非常感谢邀请我。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼和雷娜·科恩制作，由塔拉·博伊尔编辑，特别感谢我们的前实习生克洛伊·康纳利，她采访了我们在本集节目开头听到的自由派和保守派人士。我们的员工包括珍妮·施密特、帕茨·沙阿和雷内·克拉克。本周我们的无名英雄是国家公共媒体的布赖恩·马尔福德。NPM是负责销售我们赞助信息的团队。布赖恩是
liberal and conservative. He's always liberal in his encouragement and conservative in his promises. As the saying goes, he under promises and over delivers. Thanks Brian. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
自由和保守的完美结合。他在鼓励上总是自由派，在承诺上总是保守派。俗话说得好，他少许诺，多交付。谢谢你，布赖恩。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。